hey 42 here on January the 1st 2010 a
man known as the Jester appeared on
Twitter and announced he was going to
launch a cyber attack on a known Taliban
web site a former United States Special
Operations Command operative who had
served four tours in Afghanistan the
gesture weaponized his custom-made
denial of service scripts and combining
it with his own front end called Xerxes
began to perform targeted attacks on
jihadist cells that were using the
internet to recruit members the
mysterious gesture our sins taken on
WikiLeaks fortune the Westboro Baptist
Church the Taliban Gaddafi the
ecuadorian stock exchange incurred the
wrath of the hacker group Anonymous and
even taken on Russia marking each
successful attack with his catchphrase
tango down his efforts have supposedly
earned him the moniker the batsmen of
the internet by X FBI agents over 58,000
followers on Twitter and even his own
merchandise he only ever speaks in three
places Twitter is blog and his i2p IRC
channel he generally takes down anyone
who opposes the US military including
Edward Snowden and claimed to be acting
out of American patriotism and whilst he
may be known to some as the Batman of
the Internet he keeps quiet when it
comes to who his Commissioner Gordon is
all that is clear is that this gray hats
hacker vigilante is very capable very
real and very ready to take on any
threat to the US that he takes aim at
the gesture it one example of the many
vigilantes that appeared throughout
history to take the law into their own
hands and combat the in justices or
perceived injustice 'as faced by their
society but where the gesture operates
online there are many vigilantes who
have operated in the real world movies
such as Batman teachers that vigilantes
are heroic brave moral individuals
driven to take the law into their own
hands
whereas history tells us that sometimes
they can be incredibly dangerous
individuals who are often out of their
minds there have been some recent
L&T such as the so called the Bromley
Batman he was reported to be fighting
crime in London and then one day
mysteriously disappeared then there are
older examples such as John Dillinger
the famous charismatic bank robber who
operated during the Great Depression his
incredible exploits such as escaping
prison using a fake gun cars from
blackened Ward gave him enormous fame
which may have helped spawn the myth
that Dillinger was actually a Robin Hood
style vigilante who robbed from the
predatory financial institutions that
caught the depression itself whilst this
is a lovely idea and Dillinger was
generous with his friends and family
it's more factual to say that he robbed
from the rich to pay for his lavish and
[ __ ] filled lifestyle the real evidence
of vigilantism we do have however often
paints a far more violent and disturbing
image during the 1880s and 90's
southwest Missouri was ravaged by
economic ruin lawlessness and the steady
breakdown of society which left smaller
towns and villages at risk of Outlaws
Tanny County was one such village where
corruption was so rife that criminals
regularly escaped convictions as their
clans had elected that same officials
meant to serve them justice this was why
despite as many as 40 murders occurring
between 80 and 65 and 85 not one suspect
was convicted enter a man named nut and
Kinney a mysterious mountain of a man
standing at six foot six and weighing
300 pounds reported to be completely
fearless and even more persuasive
deciding he'd had enough of the
lawlessness surrounding his home he and
a group of 13 accomplices set out to
bring their own form of justice donning
horned hoods with unsettling white
outlined faces the group began to hunt
down criminals corrupted officials and
even adulterers and although they
started out with the intention to take
down criminal gangs they eventually
gained their own excessively violent
reputation
along with their reputation came a
somewhat unfortunate name the
Baldknobbers named at the same Bald Knob
summits in the Ozark Mountains where
they were says to hold secret meetings
eventually their gang grew into the
hundreds and whilst they began as a
small group dedicated to helping the
rule of law protecting people's lives
and property and stamping out
criminality and corruption the group
rapidly grew out of control in fact in
some towns the Baldknobbers had given
the town such a knobbing that they
occupied key political offices and were
essentially a ruling political faction
the Navas actions became more daring as
well such as when 100 Baldknobbers broke
into Tanny county jail kidnapped
brothers Frank and tubal Taylor and
hanged them from the neck until dead
they began to enforce social mores
frightened loose women adulterers and
husbands who beat their wives and
sometimes even branded criminals some
group members used their newfound
influence to their personal advantage
their newfound violence caused rifts
within the group with many founding
members leaving and even causing an
eventual split within the Baldknobbers
kinney's loyal followers and those who
wished and planned for his death
this new splinter group was aptly named
the anti Baldknobbers with whom they had
many violent altercations the main
difference being that the Baldknobbers
supported the north in the Civil War
whilst the anti balls and others were
Confederates all of this violence
eventually resulted in the group's being
disbanded by the government but not
before over copycat vigilante groups had
been formed in its wake one group the
Christian County Chapter burnt down
saloons and held secret meetings in
caves but they were met with swift
justice caught by the authorities free
of the founding members were sentenced
to be hanged
but the executioner's were inexperienced
used incorrect ropes and accidentally
let the free men fall to the floor where
they began to arrive around in agony a
few minutes later
were set and the men were finally hanged
and killed as fanat M Kinney he was shot
and killed in 1888 by farmer Billy miles
who claimed self-defense the killing
gained worldwide media attention and
miles was eventually released leading
sheriff Galva bouncin alongside a bounty
hunter to attempt to bring him to
justice
tracking him to an Independence Day
celebration they confronted miles and
when X balls inaba and aunty
Baldknobbers became involved in the
confrontation bullets began to fly in
both the sheriff and the Bounty Hunter
were slain whilst Billy miles escaped
unscathed and with that the Baldknobbers
story came to an end but what about
within our lifetime are there any
vigilantes in existence or recent
existence who are as violent as the
Baldknobbers well yes El Salvador is
home to one of the most terrifying drug
cartels on the planet ms.fer see ms-13
is a brutal international criminal
organization renowned for its cruelty
and ruthless pursuit of expansion the
gang grew in scope when the original
gang members were deported from the
United States to El Salvador
during the Salvadoran Civil War under
the conditions of racial persecution and
deportation ms-13 became a magnet that
disenfranchised luring them into a life
of violence but the civil war gave birth
to something much more vicious and
relentless than even ms-13 and something
with one goal to hunt and kill ms-13
wherever they were found la sombra negra
Spanish for the black shadow our
vigilante group or death squad composed
of former military and police officers
who appeared in the wake of the civil
war
targeting ms-13 and other gangs with
extremely violent and clinical attacks
designed to wipe the gang out and fill
the surviving gang members with terror
their targets included everyday gang
members all the way to politicians
judges and government officials anything
they deemed a worthy target in their
mission to socially cleanse El Salvador
the surrounding northern triangle
countries of Honduras and Guatemala
since their emergence in the mid 90s la
sombra negra have continually reimbursed
notably in 2014 when they raided a house
captured for gang members and after
torturing and killing them left their
bodies with the warning leave within
five days or face certain death or in
where a bound gagged and dead ms-13 gang
member was found alongside the ominous
Harold la sombra negra has arrived in
padai so there soryo dressed in all
black masked uniforms and armed to the
teeth with machine guns and knives la
sombra negra carries out surgical and
horrifying attacks on any gang members
they can find in many instances their
brutality outdoors that's of even the
gang itself some reports claim they
torture and sexually abused gang members
even dismembering their hands tongue
anus and genitalia then they put a
single bullet in the back of their head
of their victim their calling card
called tear dos de gracia this is where
they shoot the victim at close range
with an assault rifle which is you can
imagine blows their heads to smithereens
they then leave the brutalized body
where ms-13 can't find it often with
messages saying el idiotic sufrió una
mortal enter which is Spanish for this
idiot suffered a slow death autopsy of
some victims revealed semen adding
evidence to the rumors of sexual torture
needless to say ms-13 doesn't fear much
at all but they certainly fear the Samba
negra
but what about vigilantes who operate
alone like the common storytelling trope
of the lone gun fighter or caped
crusader fighting injustice obviously
that exists also in the real world and
there is one lone Crusader who beats
them all in the 1970s a man was seen
driving around Orange County California
in a custom-built Lincoln Continental
wearing a bright blue jumpsuit in cape
his name captain sticky his mission
justice captain sticky whose real name
was Richard pester was a self-made
entrepreneur
who after making a fortune in the
fiberglass industry decided to follow
his true calling in life to become a
peanut-butter-and-jelly themed vigilante
he brought justice to companies with
predatory consumer practices just as
Bruce Wayne would use fear to strike
terror into the hearts of criminals
Richard pester would use his love of
peanut-butter-and-jelly to land bad
companies in a sticky situation driving
around in the sticky Mobile which quite
literally fired streams of peanut butter
and jelly at people I am NOT making this
up captain sticky would confront
thieving youths and delinquents with his
spreadable arsenal but he'd soon find
himself going up against bigger foes the
self-described commander-in-chief of the
world organization against evil captain
sticky was using his striking appearance
charismatic personality and formidable
condiment fuels 350 pound frame to bring
justice to companies that didn't cut the
mustard but car rental store he's on his
way a repairman that doesn't do the job
properly he's coming for you but he is
to think captain stinky for all his
ridiculousness was actually deadly
serious and far more capable and nude
expects in fact in the late 70s he was
responsible for teeing off improved
healthcare regulations and
investigations into nursing homes and he
did this using one simple tactic Captain
sticky was beloved by almost everyone
except maybe the police but nobody loved
him more than the media using his wits
captain sticky realized that by getting
the media to follow him to do companies
he felt were using predatory practices
or generating evil in society he could
draw unwanted attention towards them and
intimidate them into cleaning up their
own act in your hearts out Batman
in fact Captain sticky arava Pesta
outlined his approach quite clearly in
an issue of NME he said a do-gooder is
pure at heart but naive to power
politics I'm sophisticated in tactics
which intimidates bureaucracies which I
feel out of
during sources of evil in our society if
I were to wear a pinstripe suit while
trying to aid the oppressed I would have
no efficiency thus my characterization
when I staged a surprise raid in my
costume you can be sure I'm not ignored
in other words captain sticky weaponized
the early stages of the attention
economy and attempted to use it for good
it's no wonder then that he developed
such a loyal following and popularity at
conventions it's also somewhat
refreshing that in a long history of
violent merciless vigilantes or rogue
online Patriots the history of
vigilantism has one individual who fits
the more childish comic-book conception
of them but no one can be a vigilante
forever pester eventually grew tired of
spreading peanut justice and returns to
entrepreneurship investing in
eco-friendly gardening products a chain
of brothels and the business that led
wild tours through Thailand and for
complicated but largely innocent reasons
he ended up briefly involved within the
porn industry
so captain sticky finally met his sticky
end thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make
these videos the links in the
description also you can get your hands
on a first edition signed copy of my new
book stick a flag in it by heading on
over to unbound and pre-ordering your
copy today thank you